what's up
guys bang bang it's lunch
money time we are not doing this
tomorrow
on thanksgiving or on friday i'll miss
you guys i will
we'll see you again on monday but before
we do that we should do the episode
today duh
i'm here with polina bang bang while
while she's trying to get rich wrestlers
just trying to get her lunch money right
and don't forget that lunch money is now
sponsored by block five here's the deal
blockbuy
is awesome i'm an investor i sit on the
board they have
products that you should use if you use
the products
then you can get really high rates of
interest you can get great loans
you can buy and sell crypto it's a
no-brainer go get a blockfy account and
in fact because we're not gonna be here
for the next two days i
have a special special idea for you if
you go and you sign up for a blockfly
account and then you
screenshot it and you tweet it over the
next couple of days before
monday i will pick one of you and i will
send you a hundred dollars
what yes but you have to screenshot
the fact that you open an account and
you gotta tweet it and if you use
hashtag blockfi
pomp that's what you gotta use hashtag
block five pump i'll give you a hundred
dollars okay let's get into the episode
today
bitcoin making moves
if you saw anthony was on cnbc this
morning talking about bitcoin
um i had nothing to do with his
background that's all
you go bitcoin hit 360 billion dollar
market cap for the first time in history
this morning bang bang bang bang bang
you say 600
360 billion it'll hit a trillion one day
just wait let's go all right next
okay we're gonna fly through this
aesthetics i'm hungry
no we're gonna do it for the people get
on the information
fintech company stripe is considered of
considering a funding round to value it
higher than the 36 billion dollars it
got on its last round
according to bloomberg the new valuation
could hit as much as 70 billion dollars
or maybe as much as a hundred billion
stripe is one of the most valuable
companies in the world either i use it
he uses it we all use it
even if their valuation doesn't prove it
i think this is going to be one of the
most important companies in the world
uh like amazon type importance
um and it would not surprise me that one
day stripe
ends up being a trillion dollar business
hold on a second
you don't think square could be that
square
is in payments but it's a different type
of payment service it's more of a
uh b2c and a peer-to-peer type payments
whereas stripe is actually the
infrastructure that people are using
to uh process payments on the internet
got it
stripe trillion dollar company you heard
it here first
they're only 36 to 100 billion right now
so that would be somewhere between a 10
to 20 x but the problem is they're in
private markets they don't want to go
public that's why they're raising more
money in the private markets
so we'll see how it plays out okay um
tesla
is recalling more than 9 500 of its
model x and model y
electric vehicles over potentially
faulty roof trim and bolts that could be
inadequately
tightened we'll see
a little a little bit going on with uh
the
whole idea of um
whether the roof trim and the bolts you
think that's a big deal
i do why because you think so
what if the roof falls no it's like the
roof's not gonna fall off
okay next topic i like that they are
taking the precaution
i like that too i like that too next
topic is oxycontin
and purdue pharma polina's thing's not
loading that's why that's why she's
freaking out
she's like doing this because she's
trying to get me to give her her phone
i'm not doing it
no so thank god we talked about it last
night at the dinner table so you know
what's
happening but it won't load because the
internet's not working purdue pharma
is has pled guilty and criminal charges
in the op in its role in the opioid
crisis
here's my here's my whole take on this
we talked about it one time before
i do not like a situation where
the sackler family which started purdue
pharma
has been able to take 13
billion dollars in wealth they made
13 billion dollars the company
has now pled guilty to some criminal
charges they're going to pay a fine
there's all kinds of issues with the
company but the individuals
the secular or
walking away with 13 billion dollars
they were never charged criminally
and they ended up agreeing to i think it
was a uh
if i remember correctly it's a 25
million civil
penalty like like a settlement so
in a world where we make it profitable
to do bad nefarious malicious things
people are going to do that all day long
if you say to somebody hey if you make
13 billion dollars doing this bad thing
and then at the end the penalty is just
you pay 25 million dollars
everyone's gonna go do it it's stupid
we have to make the penalties worse come
measure it or
worse no no that has to be worse if you
made 13 billion dollars
you need to pay us 15 billion you want
to know how quickly they'd all knock
this nonsense off
it's like the banks if all of a sudden
the banks make two billion dollars in
some scheme
and then we it's like oh you know what
you have to pay us a 50 million dollar
fine
it's literally profitable for them to
break the law because it's kind of like
the opposite of
regular everyday individuals if you get
in trouble with the law you're not
getting off
like with like ten dollar fine yeah and
i get the fact that okay cool they're
rich they've got lawyers they've got all
this kind of stuff
my point is there have been
thousands of people who have died in
this opioid crisis
and the company it's not like this is an
alleged thing now the company is
pleading
guilty they're saying yes we did this we
are
guilty for doing it but somehow
the people who were the masterminds
behind it
or walking away with 13 billion again i
actually don't even
want to get into the the complexity of
criminal charges versus not and
corporations being able to shield people
from
exposure all that kind of stuff is for a
court to decide
there's a legal system let that all play
out my problem is
you literally have people walking away
with 13 billion dollars and it was only
a 25 million dollar fine
we must make people
i i i like thought about like uh talking
there for a second and then i
like couldn't talk for a minute so i was
like
uh you think that's funny do you think
that's funny
i ain't gonna say your face is funny but
that's what i would have said if i
wanted to say something
but you can't say it yeah because i
can't say you know like this
uh we just need to make sure that we are
actually
taking money from people if they're
making money
it's easy it's not that hard like we
give you some common sense here
that's all i got to say what do you
think about this after you're done
laughing at me
it's just you saw the intent
okay i'm done all right oh i needed
what do you think um oh i say send them
all to prison but that's just
i'm too aggressive um next topic
subversive capital acquisition a special
purpose company that's growing in the
cannabis business
said it acquired two california
companies and named
sean jay-z carter is its chief
visionary officer i got 99 problems but
a spec ain't won
i got 99 problems and a spack ain't won
are we gonna keep going or so the
cannabis industry i got 99 problems but
it's back
ain't one the cannabis industry has seen
a lot of activity a lot of deals a lot
of transactions
in this world in 2020.
what the hell is jay-z doing as a
visionary
because he got 99 problems but a spack
ain't won oh my god all right
look the here's my favorite part what do
you say although we know we can't fully
redeem the injustices created by the war
on drugs we can help shape a brighter
and
inclusive future the brands we build
will pave a new path forward for legacy
rooted in
equity access and justice listen
marijuana is going to be legal
across the united states it's gonna
happen it's a foregone conclusion just
depends on how long it's gonna take
either people get on board or get out of
the way
it's a plan who cares stop acting like
all of a sudden this war on drugs worked
get out of the way weeds gonna be legal
psychedelics are gonna be legal
all of this stuff so are we just gonna
be a drugged up society
it has nothing to do we already are
drugged up society just so we're clear
we have prescription pain medications we
have all the opioids we have
alcohol like yo alcohol and sugar are
drugs
we don't think of them that way but
alcohol is
actually worse it's used by more people
and it has worse outcomes
than weed and withdrawals okay
d ready that's that's if i ever ran for
president that would be what i would say
it's ask lunch money time
you know what i would say make weed
legal make psychedelics legal
make education better by making it lower
cost
and more accessible get rid of the death
penalty and get rid of all the idiots in
office
there's probably some other things that
throw in there elena co-president um
i want to be vice president the vp vp's
got the best job
and take none of the heat gets all the
benefits
yeah like you like they'd be like why
did you make this decision the vp is
over there drinking like a pina colada
on a private jet like that guy's got to
answer all the questions
all right it's s lunch money time
d dome awesome channel pomp how do you
get started investing in private markets
i do not know where to start appreciate
any pointers you offer keep up the great
work we keep getting this question but i
think it's important
this is a bad answer don't get started
what i mean by that
is again it comes back to advantages the
best thing that most people can do
is they can find people who have an
advantage in the private markets whether
it's specific uh
industry that they're focused on a
specific strategy they just have a
network and access
whatever it is that you can find
somebody who has a real advantage
you should give them your money and just
pay the fees right and the way the
reason why i say that is
in the private market specifically there
is such
a difference between those with an
advantage versus those without
so if you basically give money to uh and
you're the random
let's say angel investor in um i don't
know indianapolis indiana
right and you're like i'm gonna start
investing in private companies and use
like
call up all the entrepreneurs in your
city and you're like hey
why don't you meet me at the coffee shop
and i'd like to invest in your business
the odds that you hit a company
that ends up being an absolute breakout
success and delivers the type of return
that you need
for an angel or venture style portfolio
to perform well
is very low instead if you give that
same money to somebody in let's say
silicon valley new york la
a fund manager a fund manager whatever
uh
then the odds they hit an outbreak
company like stripe is a perfect example
there's people investing in the seed
round the series a series b of stripe
it's now worth tens of billions of
dollars how much money do i need to give
this fund manager in order to see
returns like
is it an astronomical number no it's all
about portfolio construction right so
like
it most people are looking at the
private markets you got to be an
accredited investor meaning you have
either 200 000
a year in income for two years in a row
uh or you got to have a million dollars
in assets i think outside of your home
right uh so your your house doesn't
count as assets uh
and if you have a million dollars some
of it you're gonna keep in cash
right so let's say you keep 20 in cash
30 cash whatever the number is
some of you can put the public markets
some of you can put in the private
markets and get a figure else out maybe
got some real estate whatever it is
but ultimately let's say that you say i
want to put 20 in the private market
then once you get into the private
market you say okay do i want it all
into
equity like venture style do i want to
do some buyout uh private equity where
they like literally like leverage buyout
type stuff
or maybe what i want to do is some
private credit opportunities so then you
go okay well
what's the allocation within my private
bucket of private credit private equity
or venture capital
then once you get inside of that you say
okay my venture capital bucket ends up
being one percent of my total assets
right and so inside of that bucket i'm
going to then take one percent and i'm
going to
divvy it up among three managers then
you go and you do it and so like
the most important decisions you make in
investing which is really important
the decisions you make on asset
allocation
are almost always more important than
you make on security
uh selection and what i mean by that is
asset allocation is
how much of my portfolio is going to go
into the stock market versus the private
market versus real estate versus cash
whatever
that decision is actually way more
important than like which stock did i
buy in my stock portfolio
people don't know that but that's but
that's a really important point
julian rogers what do you think the best
asset classes will be over the next five
to ten years
obviously bitcoin and some tech stocks
but what else do you think will thrive
or grow steadily while the world
undergoes massive changes what do you
think i'm
bitcoin all the way
really yeah you think that's gonna be
the best one yeah
well i didn't think you'd say that okay
i mean what other asset classes are
there so i definitely
i've been brainwashed i definitely think
bitcoin by far outperforms everything
uh the second thing that i would say is
uh i'm fascinated with psychedelics oh
yeah
um i think that just the the regulatory
kind of uh capture that's been there is
gonna get removed
that's gonna be a massive wave uh
cannabis is somewhat related to that
um another thing that i think is really
interesting is this whole idea
of um quantified self sorry
quantified self is another one uh like
automated content
so the ability to uh create um
kind of fake videos fake audio all that
kind of stuff but use it for good
purposes not nefarious purposes i think
that'll be big
basically the way that i think about
investing uh kind of like for the next
five to ten years
i call it investing at the fringes so
what i mean by that is if you think of
like okay you have this bullseye and
that's where everyone else is investing
they're investing in the s p they're
investing in bonds they're investing in
kind of like very like down the fairway
or bullseye type stuff
where you actually want to invest if
you're looking for really outsized
returns
is around the fringes right so the
farther you get away from the bullseye
the better off you are going to be if
you're right tell me about the criminals
well so the whole key the whole key to
investing is you got to do something
different than everybody else right so
you don't want to invest in everything
else because that's a commoditized
return you do something different than
everybody else and you got to be right
bitcoin was a great um idea or kind of
fit that thesis
a number of years ago five years from
now bitcoin will probably be a consensus
trade
uh and therefore the return profile will
actually kind of the future return
profile be
going down the other thing that i think
is really interesting
is basically looking at uh what are
15 to 25 year old kids today if you talk
to them
what are the things that they're like
duh this is gonna happen that older
people don't actually agree with
right so bitcoin is one example digital
assets uh but there's other things right
uh so like uh cannabis legalization
there's a lot of people over the age of
45
50 who are like no way that'll never
happen the united states war on drugs
you know i grew up on that whatever
young people are like duh of course it's
going to be and so what you actually
want to do is you want to arbitrage on
the demographics or the
the psycho uh graphics of
uh their understanding of society so
there are things that young people
believe that older people don't
it's not a knock against older people
it's not an advantage to younger people
it's just that's what they did
right a certain generation grew up with
a cell phone in their hand they
understood a different society than the
people who grew up without it
and so that's one of the key pieces to
investing is just go talk to young
people and just
talk to them about different what
technologies are you interested in where
do you spend your time what's on your
phone all that kind of stuff
and you'll uncover a bunch of anthony
messina can you please show us your
process for planning your day
and time management tips go ahead oh you
want me to start yeah we have three
minutes and then i have to get on a call
why you always gonna cut a short here
all right
because you would talk for three hours
well if you could
talk and we wouldn't have this problem
okay she's so impressed with herself
right there so
always impressed with myself so for me
time management
comes down to i keep a calendar
on my computer and i have a physical
planner so like
writing things down really helps me and
crossing things off is very
mentally soothing um but i uh
bucket my days into like mondays and
tuesdays i work on the wednesday
profile dossier thursdays fridays and
saturdays are reserved for the sunday
email so technically my days off or
wednesdays and sundays
but i do that because it just helps me
uh prioritize my time
and i also always try to make you know
30
reserve 30 minutes to an hour to get
away from technology and just go
do a physical activity whether it's
running yoga something like that
next no yo what is your oh me plan my
day it's all on my calendar if it's not
on my calendar i don't do it
he could be better about his time man
that's why i'm not answering this
question
all right i sit on twitter a lot i like
to tweet i like to read things whatever
that's it for today guys happy
thanksgiving
go and tweet a screenshot that you have
a block by account use hashtag
blockbypomp and i'll send somebody a
hundred bucks
see ya bangbang hope you guys enjoyed
this episode of lunch money
as much as we did and don't forget lunch
money is now sponsored by block five
so go check them out there's a link in
the description that you can click on
i'm an investor
a user and a huge fan
what you're a bigger fan of block five
than you are of me
block five is my second favorite thing
in the world behind polina they've got
three products
they can give you a us dollar loan you
can earn up to eight point six percent
interest on an interest bearing account
or you can buy and sell cryptocurrencies
on their crypto exchange
i personally use the interest bearing
account there's not very many places
where you'll find
up to 8.6 interest on a deposit in an
interest bearing account
go do your own research there's risks
associated but 8.6
is pretty compelling so click on the
link in the description say thanks to
the folks at blockfly
subscribe to our channel like the video
annoy pulling in the comments
and we'll see you guys tomorrow and be
kind to your friends